meet bloomberg's own david nicholson
now his happy place is out in the field
on the open road
but like the rest of the world lately
he's been working from home
a lot more than he's used to kovit 19
has prompted a massive urban exodus as
professionals of every ilk
yearn for more space to live and work as
a result
rural areas have exploded and they're
poised to experience a resurgence
as more and more families pack up and
leave the big city
to try out life in the burbs but there's
one problem with that
not all internet speeds are created
equal
anyone who might need to upload or
download large files for a living
may not want to pack up and move to that
cabin in the woods just yet
now david's house isn't a cabin but it
is in the woods
and inexplicably his internet is
workable
my internet is okay i pay a lot for it
it's around 140 a month the download
speed's great
and the upload speed is terrible which
is really bad for my work because i have
to
upload these massive files but i'm
definitely one of the more lucky ones
in this community just a few miles down
the road my buddy has awful internet
it's usually under two down and
under 0.2 up so it's it's often unusable
some days it's around one
and other times it'll drop down to about
0.2.3 i just want to be able to
have internet at my house without having
to go outside the
normal ways of acquiring internet
it's it's really frustrating we're
literally
miles a few miles away from downtown
and it just cuts off this is a problem
and the solutions
are not there yet because getting
high-speed internet in rural areas on
mass
is something our providers may simply
not be ready for
if your internet service doesn't have
fast download and upload speeds
then you don't have high speed harmony
you have
americans on average pay about 70 a
month for internet at home
but in rural areas it could cost a lot
more for a lot less service
so the pricing uh for a fixed wireless
provider here
can be something between 80 and 150
dollars for about 25 megabits per second
however gigabit service which is a
thousand megabits per second and
symmetrical
is running at about 119 a month or 130 a
month
that's john paul he co-owns spiral fiber
an internet service provider here in
nevada county california
and for the past 10 years he's been
trying to bring an affordable fiber
optic network
to town it all started when he applied
to be part of the pilot program for
google's fiber service
across the country civic boosters have
been going to extremes
chanting singing
and marching trying to get the search
engine giant to look at their town
the internet these days is crucial to be
in the world
to be a part of the world and to be
connected to your community
google ultimately went with kansas city
missouri which left paul on a mission to
get funding to lay out fiber optic
networks for gigabit service
over the next several years he would
attend conferences
and pitch venture capitalists and apply
for grants
to make his vision come to life one of
the biggest roadblocks
to building infrastructure for the
internet here in the united states
are the existing large providers they
have their
land staked out they would prefer that
nobody come in and compete against them
in 2013 we applied for a grant we went
down and met with the commissioners at
the california public utilities
commission it was an arduous process to
get funded
but we finally did against all odds we
got a 16 million dollar grant and then
we went out to seek venture capital
then in march of 2020 the pandemic hit
the world
everybody got locked down and everybody
came home
and everybody started using the internet
and i remember seeing on one of the
local
fixed wireless providers websites
they've said hey we know you're all
staying home
but please don't use too much video and
please don't use too much bandwidth and
i thought
that doesn't work the us connectivity
gap is far greater
compared to countries that are
considered its peers economically
some developing nations actually have
better internet than rural america
like in kenya which has a
state-of-the-art fiber optic network
fed in from their coastline the american
connectivity gap does largely affect
rural areas that are either outside of
service coverage
or simply prohibitively expensive
this is rebecca she and her family moved
to nevada county just a couple miles
down the road from david
they took for granted that high-speed
internet would just exist in the area
and it's not something they even
bothered to check on before buying their
house
turns out all they got was dial-up we
wanted to move where we had a little
more space
room for the kids to run around you know
just be out in the mountains a little
bit more
having come from a bigger city area
where wi-fi is pretty readily available
we hadn't really considered that
in our purchasing of the house whether
that would be an option or not
when school started and now that we are
remote learning with our children
and we're doing everything from home we
didn't have the option to do that at our
house so every day when
school would start we'd have to pack the
kids up and we'd go to
my in-laws home they have a little cabin
up in this area that does have wi-fi
already
rebecca's situation is the norm in rural
america
according to data from the federal
communications commission
just four percent of urban americans
lack access to
broadband internet that's compared to
almost
40 percent of people who live in rural
areas
while that was the case there were also
racial and socio-economic divides in
terms of who had that access
in addition to that geographic
difference low-income african-american
students latino students and
first-generation
college students were more likely than
others to have only one device at home
that shared among multiple siblings and
or lack
access to that actual connection
for most american towns there's also a
lack of competition
forcing internet prices up and large
providers like at t
and comcast aren't incentivized to
expand service to these rural
communities
this is how xfinity makes life simple
easy
so in our area we have a small imprint
of comcast
but they're not going to go out to the
more rural areas it's just not cost
effective for them to do it as a large
company
in order to lay fiber cable you're
actually physically digging trenches
into the ground and for internet service
providers
they're primarily focused on maximizing
their profits
and so the fewer customers you have you
know in any square mile and the more
fiber you have to lay
that's just kind of harder to pencil out
from a purely economic standpoint
at t released a statement on the matter
expressing the need and desire for
government assistance
to fund fiber optic expansion to areas
deemed
unprofitable comcast released a similar
statement encouraging more
public-private collaboration on this
effort
federal agencies do offer grants to help
communities build broadband networks but
many have argued that there's not enough
flexibility on how to use these funds
the covet 19 relief package passed by
congress in march
and signed by president donald trump
awarded 43.3 million dollars to 51
projects
on the east coast alone but it also
stipulated that these projects needed to
be up and running
by december 30th for contractors who
plan projects
months and years in advance it's a
scramble to rearrange their schedules to
meet that deadline
so what we've been asking the federal
government to to consider
is at least as long as the projects are
getting started
knowing the projects are being put into
place to expand both remote learning
uh working from home and opportunities
like that that are truly driven from
covid we're moving as fast as we can
regardless but hopefully they'll give us
some more time
talking to john paul it's clear that he
believes
broadband is something that can
transform a community and should be
considered
a public good one of the first
communities to come on in the united
states with full-on gigabit service was
chattanooga tennessee now they're a
bigger city but they're a city that was
economically in a downturn in the last
15 years
the city of chattanooga has turned
around in an amazing way
it's a nexus for young people to move to
it's a place where technology happens
it's not just about logging on to zoom
you know to
connect with your colleagues who might
be in new york city
it's also your ability as a small
business
you know operating in the town of nevada
city or wherever it may be
to you know quickly upload your
payroll documents or something onto the
cloud or to
quickly you know swipe a customer's
credit card
there's just some really basic business
functions and mechanics that i think
people in big cities really take for
granted
and that are just going to be a much
bigger challenge for small business
owners
in rural areas
you